[Music]
yeah
I want to go
I'll talk to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey welcome back to the basement yeah we
are your hosts this is I'm the Danish
though Neil yeah we're in the basement
it smells a little funky cuz we got that
broccoli yeah we always keep a lot of
broccoli in the basement I'm
refrigerated just you never know when
you need to put it in a martini glass
you never know who's gonna come over and
be like you don't have any [ __ ]
broccoli I'm leaving I added in a bowl
once in my guess where they thought I
was a loser
you needed a martini yeah yeah yeah of
course you last it up yeah yeah you just
have like free-range broccoli you can't
have that the good thing is you can just
throw the whole thing in the blender
with the glass and yeah yeah or dump the
broccoli out break the glass and stab
somebody and take an apple that's a good
all right ladies and gentlemen you know
the deal let's dig in to this week's
video in the words of Peter Pan I never
want to grow up
can't play down the freeze
[Music]
all right you see the outfit by the way
she looks like Jim Carrey and the scene
from Ace Ventura when he had the tutu on
and he goes yeah let's give this a
little context this young lady she is
into pretending that she's a toddler and
toddler plays yeah call it on the
streets and evidently this dude's
totally fine with it so this is like the
starter kit for the man to how to be a
pedophile
yeah it's fixed find a chick who just
wants to be a toddler then work your way
up to a real toddler weirds me out he's
like I want to be a toddler but I also
want to have tattoos and gauge earrings
at the same time yeah you got to commit
to it
hey it's 2019 you could have whatever
you want these days I bet the people who
do Peppa Pig when they wrote these books
were like this is the audience that
we're going for 100 perspective perverts
in their girlfriends they were actually
shocked that kids enjoyed the book there
is for 20 year old women who like to be
toddlers all right let's get back into
this horrible little and
it is extreme love I agree with them
beautiful shot Kentucky us ashes
fantastic as opposed to Kentucky Russia
interpreters and Hills and grotesque
Gardens where ashes take the form of
houses and chimneys
what they're doing is showing the
dichotomy of it is proving she can read
she's reading Fitzgerald and then
they're gonna show her playing with her
own [ __ ] you're the cats are like why do
we why are we involved in this it was
luck of the draw cat you have to be
stuck with these freaks 20 but not
really cuz I'm five no no really you are
twenty that was Johnny we posit sale
again a quarter lock it can he be tried
as a pedophile they feel like at any
point like she was five at the time of
the incident at the time of the
penetration he's like she told me she
was 20 but then she turned into five
yeah or he could sue her being like I
thought she was fine when I met her
online and Samara is really hitting me
like I feel like is this okay to eat oh
it's all that's stage oh boy especially
on that farm to Austin farm to coffee
table let's dig deeper into this video
please my name is Johnny and I'm
and I am a creep no way it's not really
gonna Park daddy baby why she dress like
she's in the movie Grease yeah I would
going with this big video G by
definition is daddy dawn little girl and
it is a subsection of BDSM which is a
part of kink I was just discovering
things about the community learning a
bit more about it I decided to try it
out and so just love that every
basically being like this is a sexual
fetish there are a lot of people in the
community that do this sexually and I'm
not one of those people this is a closet
hold on hold on that's like I'm into
bestiality but it's non-sexual
bestiality yeah which a lot of people
are into yeah it's just for love of the
game yeah I just cuddle with a horse or
a dog how can it be BDSM and non-sexual
it makes no sense she's saying it's kink
yeah and this guy is also being like oh
yeah by the way totally not attracted to
this whatsoever
non-sexual kink they do this like around
their families yeah it Thanksgiving real
dads are you talking about creep that's
over here talking about your biological
father who hates you
what are you talking about it's sexual
predator yeah let's be honest who's
inviting these [ __ ] freaks to
Thanksgiving dinner by the way
we should say alleged predator yeah we
don't want any lawsuits from Johnny yeah
drag to the core with beef I don't want
a problem of it more as dog yeah we
don't want her to take the stand and
throw a temper tantrum Oh Fargo gotta
let us does he go to date you take her
to daycare during the day I bet they've
tried and people are like yeah [ __ ] out
of here do they know but it's non-sexual
King everyone knows that yeah okay keep
telling yourself that lie it's the new
oxymoron it's jumbo shrimp and non
sexual kink
jumbo shrimps a real thing it's an
oxymoron have you ever seen a little
baby shrimp yeah I'm raising one
all right let's get back down these
great people sexually I mean I'm not one
of those people this is a completely
non-sexual lifestyle for me why do we
max first time we had all these
five-year-olds dressed like [ __ ] she
was watching she showed me the sippy cup
and then she was eating these babies
next it's like a professor sweater off
it's when we had the conversation and a
rapist there oh there's other kids
there's families and they're like get
away from them kids they should not be
allowed if not real parks there should
be a pervert park for adults yeah
why were there was my childhood knock
this lady out for the sake of the other
kid go not for that there's got to be a
pervert park
[ __ ] idiot look at that lady's like
dude stay the [ __ ] away from one there
should be a policeman at all times at
the park right in there
I'm all for enjoying a park by the way
with him I'm little when I want to be
positive little what do you find
creepier her talking as a real self or
her talking is the child both of us with
you it's creepy either way pause it's a
commercial for like with Special
Olympics or something the timer life in
there Moana doll twenty year old woman I
do have a confession I like to pretend
I'm like only 24 when I go to the park
oh yeah just get back to your youth yeah
Mike look at this I pretend like it's a
studly 24 year old guy out there look at
all these older hot moms I pretend like
every day is my 21st birthday it's what
you're always drunk yeah wasted at all
times in the floor room and you have a
beer bong with you at all times
yeah you're telling them from body shots
and a rock-hard dick all right let's get
back to it
um I'm little when it's right to be but
of course just no it's not
thing that like I can't control like if
we robbed a whole depository like I like
how she threw like it's not something I
can't control
oh yeah we thought it was just [ __ ]
like The Incredible Hulk yeah it's like
don't make me mad turn it to a
five-year-old Oh piss my pants oh yeah
don't show me a salami sandwich it's
gonna make me become a toddler you know
how like back in the day I think it was
Chinese people bound people's feet to
make them smaller yeah do you think she
like did something to make her tip
smaller Richard Sipe that's one and what
are they can you tell the five-year-old
would like a full see here can you put a
book you can you put him on the screen
under my head say they're a b-cup all
right necklace when she goes to the eye
doctor does she say these the kind of
glasses of five-year-old would where
would you go to a wedding that was like
she was as the five-year-old yeah she's
going down the aisle and all the way
yeah I was throw paint on her and
brought out a PETA protea I would bring
mashed potatoes and like don't just
randomly like shout daddy because that's
involving other people and something
that they didn't consent to yeah like
this parson what you're doing right now
this guy's being like you see those
people don't ever grow up to be like
them if you do I'll kill you
Oh got his pants all wet you know what
pause it for a second if he were a real
daddy he'd be like god dammit you got my
[ __ ] shoes all wet don't be jumping
in puddles anymore yeah there's no
discipline yeah and he just seems like
he's along for the ride he doesn't seem
like he really enjoys you should be more
irritated by this child yep I miss far
around you yeah [ __ ]
this guy's worked all day long he's like
I gotta go to the [ __ ] Park he's got
to be on his phone he's got his keys
hanging out of his back pocket he's
living a hard life here janitor I was
hope so okay Opie does that well yeah
all right layouts
we'll get to the end
[Music]
hi-yah
that's racist cultural appropriation
what are their neighbors things here
feel like let's just burn the building
down hopefully they'll be in there
oh there's neighbor my daddy takes care
of me but I also take care of him we
take care of each other and I think
having that nurturing five makes it
strong there's actually a good part
right here watcher grab this jug of milk
[Laughter]
this is what we have most of our stack
around these stuffed animals this looks
like if you kidnap someone and you try
to make them feel at home you're like
here's your corner look at all these
stuffed animals that's great how are you
gonna duct about a lot of them
vegetables those aren't real vegetables
by the way like that
oh she cut the avocado good job a bad
does this cameraman an extensive list of
rules but the main ones who wrote him no
to terms no saying no and those are the
second what so she wrote these what
happens when she has a tantrum something
tells me something sexually happened I
think the guy stabs her yeah with this
week what are you talking about you
don't have rules like this up in your
house for yourself
of course yeah I know tantrums don't
tell daddy no those are helpful
reminders for anybody oh my god oh my
sexual though I think we get there yeah
you get the gist of this video they're
damaged we don't know how they've been
damaged but I'm sure that any
psychologist that's watching right now
as a diagnosis for them before we move
on from here we found somebody who's on
the opposite end of the
toddler spectrum he actually believes
that he's an old man take a look at this
video that we put together [ __ ] out of
here I'll call the goddamn police now
[ __ ] ball he got your [ __ ] ball
you piece of [ __ ] rob the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm John 37 years old and I'm in a
geriatric play and I'm Lisa his wife and
I play his granddaughter yeah I spend
most of my time as a 94 year old World
War 2 vet Oh grandpa
oh gosh are you oh my back I know come
on let's go oh he'll be back yeah yeah
come on
it's a GDG which is a grandfather Dom
granddaughter
it's a subsection of BDSM which is part
of the underworld kink and this is the
incest kink community but purely
non-sexual incest kink by the way
non-sexual yeah it's uh just a loving
grandfather and she's my caring and
sweet granddaughter holy [ __ ]
what are you doing out here we're online
we're home we're home you're at your
home right here hurry
I'm Lisa and your granddaughter we gotta
get you inside and get you in a hot bath
you're ice cold Oh kiss to show you my
appreciation
well we actually met at a nursing home
where I was working I saw this handsome
older man playing shuffleboard but
imagine my disappointment when I found
out he was 37 but you know what it is
it's it's truly like they say you're
you're as old as you feel
94 94 grandpa how's it going in there oh
not good okay they're trying to pitch
like five minutes now goddamn prostate
size a [ __ ] watermelon whoa come on
let's hurry up I don't want you to be
late to the pancake breakfast at the VFW
let's go oh my back maybe I can help
yeah sure what's going on in here
oh yeah yeah okay okay
keep it coming milk it milk it we got a
full stream we got a full stream now
yeah yeah that's it oh okay I mean the
good news is is that I could potentially
live to be like 143 yeah oh got that
going for me music well here's your
prune juice your your pills get it in
there oh that was a good set you see
under the tongue all the way yeah I'm
good good meringue kid yeah leave your
pea Bacchus
honestly I don't really understand
people that do this for sexual
gratification yeah that's really gross
it's like I mean they're animals people
should be shot
honestly people can think what they want
but I'm happy John's happy that's all
that matters water okay are you deaf
like what okay I heard you the first
time grandpa [ __ ] are you [ __ ] pants
[ __ ] prune juice we don't agree on a
lot of things one thing we do agree upon
geriatric play man Oh crazy how great
was that that was informative and
refreshing absolutely it's good to see
that that woman's not alone now let's
move on to people I don't in the middle
of the spectrum I guess who were it's a
new trend in Russia posing with bears
yeah so this first video is a lovely
young lady video it's a picture or
picture come on man you're losing it and
she has some of the highest boots I've
ever seen in my life those are bear
posing boots it'll make them in the u.s.
nobody the US you already waivers you
got the sign to pose with a bear in the
US yeah this really is a Russia
I think exclusive deal and she's eating
oh do you think this bear was bullying
her and she threw candy in its face if
you watched the previous episode you
know what we were talking about I'm not
a political person at all but I heard
this bear may have been involved in our
previous election did some bear
tampering I think you could've hired
it's just a man in a bear suit is the
bear smelling her fingers what is
happening in this picture yeah she just
had ate a Stromboli sandwich egg
Stromboli's and Russian baby you have to
actually dip your fingers at its crumbly
sandwich in order to calm this thing's
nerves would you I wouldn't be would you
be come from no not at all well hide you
I don't know if you've seen any bear
attack movies or videos but they always
come from behind they grabbed her neck
right there you seen bear attack three
no but I saw two oh they look real she's
going tongue to tongue where's her
[ __ ] in that it's it looks fake I
think it's it's riding high you know
like when you would take like a Barbie
doll you move the leg it looks all crazy
yeah horses off people wrench kissing
wrong the tongue with this do you think
that he just got into a honey hive I
think they were scissoring right before
this and this is kind of the end of the
scene why not it would crush you this is
a prom picture I think I like how she's
wearing a Miami Florida shirt like she
could fool us that this may be my is
this Miami that
this definitely has the characteristics
of florida but it happens to be Russia
which is the as far as countries go it's
the Florida of countries why are they
trying to make this bear like the most
like sexual like look at this none of a
bear we have in Russia I think this
might be a jab at the US that Russia is
proving that they're bears are like
[ __ ] more than our bears here I call
this photo
pause near the [ __ ] if I were to name
it why was that lady the only one that
French kiss you think that costs extra
for the photo shoot and the bear looks
sad like it's like I'd rather be in a
zoo than have to do this so it looks
like it's trying to look down or sure
that you giving me a little bit but I
want more well if there's just one of
Putin it was just grabbing the bear just
grabbing his dick he's just biting down
on it teeth are broken cuz brass [ __ ] oh
brass [ __ ] Putin which is a common
medical condition this is what a bizarre
trend to be the first like who's the
first he's like I want to get into this
and then other women are like oh I want
to be like Svetlana they're PETA and
Russia I'm gonna say no Peter like and
hummus yeah oh I think probably I was
just wondering if we could go to Russia
with our broccoli martini oh yeah yeah
well they eat it with PETA you want to
know when you travel to Russia they have
available yes okay yes I think so it's
still available there yeah you I don't
think there's actually the PETA the
organisation doesn't exist in Russia
okay it's it's People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals oh okay yeah oh all
right well let's move on speaking of
Ethical Treatment of Animals this next
one's a doozy you know you're in for a
treat watch it again that was the best
fall I've ever seen him I may have been
dead the way he fell you know it felt
like a tree beach I think it shoved his
nuts and it hit him in the heart
I don't know if wearing the speedo
caused more bodily injury why was he
wearing this you know what I you could
see the horse looking back I think if he
was wearing a bag year
swim trunk it wouldn't have been able to
locate the nuts like it did do you think
the horse kicked him cuz he the horse is
tired people wearing Speedos on
I think said he kicked him cuz he's
tired of people what kind of Beach is
this where horses are just what do you
think this guy brought his horse to the
beach you've never heard a horse beach
in Maryland no I've never heard of it I
guess this is a beach in Marin well
there are wild horses and their signs up
says don't touch the horses and this guy
he got a little too loose I miss this
well I thought this guy brought his
horse from home I'll show off at the
beach you stay at the beach after you
get kicked in the balls by a horse at
you just go home I think you try to
laugh it off like hahaha Hospital you
get on your boogie board and try to get
the cold water on your balls to get some
I think I think you have to leave I
don't think you can recover from that
what they don't tell you is that he was
erected here because there was a topless
woman just off camera in the beach isn't
that have horses and topless women and
families at the best beach in the world
we should give its name out yeah I don't
know what this guy was thinking but
definitely that horse has been tired of
being petted petted or [ __ ]
what are the two because he's scantily
clad coming up from behind it it's like
never again I promise and what you don't
see is the guy actually had a step stool
that's out of frame yeah that he had
brought to the beach would you bring the
step stool to the beach he had a kid's
bucket borrow your bucket for a second
what are you gonna make a castle no I'm
gonna go [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna make a
castle alright what do you think of the
guy who crosses frame
he seems drunk the guy in the flower I'm
mad at him cuz he almost ruined that
that shot that is locked the perfectly
timed horse hitting them in the nuts and
they're like take two could we get that
again can we see if I gotta see it again
I can't get enough of it I love this
calypso music yes seriously who DJ this
video no DJ Khaled who's like you know
what this horse shot in the nuts isn't
enough we got to put some music to it
how much horse [ __ ] is on this beach by
the way are you as you were asking me
I'd say like 17 pounds yeah I mean I
would not what
go to this Beach at all I don't wanna go
to a beach we're worried about like a
horse taking a [ __ ] or have you ever
seen a horse piss have you seen the
splatter just last night I was at a
urinal next to one did they swim in the
water like can you be in the waves and
this is like a horse next no the horses
usually just go there for barbecues
whatever your body surfing and you just
nail a horse in the body with your head
Oh with your neck horses have the right
away in the water I would love to see a
shark just attack a horse and ocean
believe Oh horse for sure kick the shark
in the balls kick him in the nose yeah
nose look at the guy look back at the
horse like how dare you
do you know who I am I'm a lawyer yeah
I'm gonna fill you in the cold [ __ ] my
family owns this beach maybe this guy is
litigious and he's looking for a lawsuit
he came to this Beach like I'm gonna get
kicked in the balls I'm suing I'm suing
Marilyn suing everybody what do you
think the girls getting out of the
cooler
oh I thought that was a garbage bin I
thought she saw like some buds that were
barely used
did someone toss that she's like oh this
will be great with my hot dog
you think this guy was seriously like
lasting damage I hope this guy's
fathered all the children he wants cuz I
don't think it's happening anymore you
look and you're being related to this
guy and you watch this video you look at
that grandpa it'd be pretty embarrassing
why is he putting horses on the beach at
speed oh who cares like who's like I
can't resist petting a horse I know they
told me not to but I need it this guy
looks like he just took his [ __ ] max off
to come to the beach yeah you didn't
want the lines yeah tan line yeah ah all
right well there it is folks I guess
we've learned a valuable lesson don't go
to the beach yes they wait for the
[ __ ] pizzas horses all right let's
move on its next one let's stay in the
animal kingdom with this one why it's
worried about animals soul mates I
didn't want a pet grasshopper this is
creepy what kind of statement is that I
didn't want a pet grasshopper you've
never said that no I've never said that
I just say that every day of the week
and the next thing I know I end up with
five pets
it's true won't get enough who left the
grasshopper crawl over there I like your
it's insane well evidently this way
let's find out what this lady's problem
is form a relationship like super all
over me this thing has a personality
she literally learned a Jeremiah like
her mandible it looked like she had a
smiley and then she would like wipe her
face like this like a little dog
I had compassion posit how lonely do you
have to be to start giving human
qualities to a [ __ ] grasshop I don't
know but will you have that sort of
accent it's hard to land somebody it'll
stay for a while listen to it like a
little dog look at this look at this
grasshopper what is she [ __ ] talking
about by the way it has a personality I
you can tell the thing was a wild card
jokester oh it did wink at me I did see
that did you see it went like this to
her she's like one all pranksters wow
what a whack job it was dog on her lap
what is that her fur coat oh she's in
the grass opera is a distraction okay
let's continue on but I noticed she was
missing a hind leg and the other one was
like kind of misshapen other male roles
[Music]
on my Hanuman a statement literally
crawled right out by in cool technology
yeah it would probably like kill me my
[ __ ] leg is broken this kiss hurts
that was a sign from God that she had to
take it cooled on her hand
it's thing as a personality but
evidently doesn't give a [ __ ] that its
leg is all the way out here how do you
think it lost its leg oh it's probably
like a 20 year old woman who also
identifies as a 5 year old toddler when
she bit it off she broke it she was
confused yet her dad spanked her in a
non-sexual way you Nazi rule number 18
don't harm animal yeah don't bring
Christ off now I'm gonna have to [ __ ]
you in a non-sexual way yeah to teach
you a lesson alright let's watch it
crawl on her hand some more
for entomologist so the entomologist
addicted that their lifespan is wait
posit you casually just say the mahalia
who's the entomologist their neighbor
don't you have an entomologist that you
go to yeah I have a podiatrist that
other doctors and in my entomology
entomologist oh yeah I look him up in
the phone book all the time and they're
like what do you have oh you have a
grasshopper yeah bring it on oh you
cooled on your hand
it's okay Jersey all right Jersey Shore
grasshoppers September and they lay eggs
that's their final stage of life then
they passed oh that's sad tongues did
you have many more days left if I end up
going to the pet store dad what this
nice terrarium I really pause it for a
second that's not so she's like give it
the best life possible
yeah that's not living outside it's
putting him in a cage with this terribly
injured leg let him eat some [ __ ]
off of this straw you didn't here's a
nice terrarium instead of being like hey
I have a whole family out here he was
limping around it would even it wanted
to be in there maybe that's not a limp
maybe that's his pant the one who's out
there trying to bang other grasshoppers
he wanted to smell her heavy perfume
what is she feeding it the caviar looks
like tapioca who goes to the
entomologist is it sounds like a shitty
romantic comedy there like this
grasshopper only has a few months to
live
she's like I'm gonna do the grasshopper
bucket list
hey travel the country I mean the best
time of their lives
and then she falls in love with
entomologist non-sexually yeah of course
yeah all right let's go she would come
out of the tank to go on the day that
you put me out of my misery I want to
die I'm your mom people think you are
you're not just like scary hate so you
know it's a grasshopper stone did she
first laid eggs it's like oh no this is
like not good and I spoke to the
entomologist they were like stop calling
me loop is my number
I hate you I'm a scientist I don't talk
to my dad we gotta get this dirt it's
outside like this you know this is what
has to happen which is having very very
BA I'm hoping babies should put the eggs
inside her vagina
grasshopper bucket list of like things
like she ate o Cheerios cross that off
the list that's a life well-lived done
seen a nice name she decided to be tall
yeah we can't believe it it's a [ __ ]
alright well that's all we got for today
hey bud she probably had a huge
following
did she just wave no she didn't kind of
the grasshopper you [ __ ] idiot it she
just waved just supposed to show you
what shitty people we are grass hopper
got a perfect SAT score I believe it sit
on my bed doing makeup to make sure she
was okay and I looked over get another
grasshopper it's not hard out another
grass what a heartwarming she needs to
talk to a specialist something's wrong
at the entomology these authors like I
can't treat your mental problems your
intelligence we're such [ __ ] though
we just picked [ __ ] up and we're like oh
look we'll put a personality on this
thing that doesn't belong in our home
we're not doing as bad as the Russians
though so that's a victory that's true
yeah well you guys this is the portion
of the show where we like to introduce
new comedians to the world well that's
where I'm gonna correct you though
because the audience voted they sent in
their text to name it you know Neely oh
really
Danish no Neil tax charges do apply and
they voted
charges right into our pocket they voted
Frank Chow back to the Danish I head
back to the base Wow he got an
overwhelming response
okay well let's bring out Frank ciao
ciao everybody Ronnie oh ho chef Dennis
ye Wei Yong Yong don't wait way Ward and
I who obey our I change each um Wong
sure change a new show true like a yahoo
Shannon's oh yeah strong opening number
Ronnie oh sri gopala joshua ET n me gay
walk the moutains holla
doctor watch what wasn't it oh you got
served jeff Dennis Boucherie go feed on
your mother gallo an wash WA Nisha you
go shop yeah classic charm Tony to go
dancing 40 tiny condo chain shirt a
woman and sound true Shinhwa Changjo
nyada's info
[Music]
um Ryan O'Neal younger washer hey need a
walk yeah la mega-mega intro ha
Schroders armata yeah but I told you buy
low sell high kick off you go she died
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yourself
got my billet who's that it's an Asian
guys singing
[Music]